الخطاب الذي يعبر عنه الامير محمد بن
سلمان
بالنسبه للكثير من المثقفين وكانها يتحدث
باسمهم يعني
[موسيقى]
نعم نعم هي يعني
خبرتنا مع الصحوه هي جزء من وعينا يعني من
وعي كل المثقفين المشتغلين بالفلسفه هي
تشغلنا حتى قد اعتقد انها تحولت ربما الى
اللاوعي لدينا ان ان كل ما شاهدنا حاله من
حالات الانفتاح كل ما شاهدنا مشهد من
اقبال الاجيال الجديده على الفكر الحر على
الفنون على
الاستمتاع بالحياه كاننا نتنفس
الاكسجين الذي حرمتنا منه الصحوه لفترات
طويله فنحن نعي بشكل عميق جدا
التحول الجذري الذي يحدث لكن ايضا انا
اشارك الدكتور سعيد السراحي هذا القلق ان
في الاخير لابد من تاسيس ولا بد من تعميق
لهذه التجربه ولابد من تحويلها الى روح
وتفكير كل الاسباب التي ادت الى تمكن
الصحوي من المجتمع
سجنه في مفاهيمها لفتره طويله من الزمن
نعم يعني لماذا
لماذا كان جيل والدي اكثر انفتاحا من جيلي
هذا سؤال كثير جدا يعني
يجب التفكير فيه لماذا كان ابانا اكثر
انفتاحا واقبالا على الحياه
وتعاملا بشكل الطف واهدى مع قضايا كثيره
نحن
حرمنا منها ووقفت يعني حجر عثره في وجه
حياتنا هذا سؤال معناه ان جيلنا نمر يعني
بخبره قاسيه جدا